colton starts off this hour in nashville
hi colton how are you i'm good how are
you guys
great how can we help good hey
so i'm kind of uh just
i mean this is a good stress to have i
guess um to a degree so i have
um right now about 7 000
um in credit card debt and then
6 000 in student loans and then we have
about
uh 25 000 in my
vice car and then we have
um we're about to close on our first
house and
we are gonna need to put down um around
twenty
000 to avoid pmi and
we have currently sitting in our
checkings around
um 87 000 and so i guess my question is
um do i obviously i'm gonna have the 21
000 coming out in about a month for the
house
um do i tackle all these debts um
right now because we have the money or
i guess just kind of um get in the house
get that settled and then
what are those debts total um
so debt total um were about
38 000 with the car student loans my
credit card back
okay all right well we teach folks not
to buy home until you're debt-free and
have your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses in place but it
sounds like we can do all three things
with eighty thousand dollars
yep yeah yeah so write a check and be
debt free today
a series of checks put
21 000 aside for your down payment
and set the rest of it aside as your
three to six months of expenses for your
emergency fund
yep okay colton if you if you do
all of those if you do all of that
after the 87 000 you would still have 21
000
left as part of your three to six month
emergency fund
yeah and i and i think that that just
stresses me out because in my mind i
hate being under a certain amount in our
account
then you should sell your car what's up
then you should sell your car i should
sell my car
yeah your car is causing you stress or
you shouldn't buy this house it's
causing you stress
because when you start buying a bunch of
crap that you don't pay for
and you don't admit it yeah
then that and you act like you don't
have stress because the money's laying
over there in your account
that's that's falsehood that that's a
that's a foe
that's a faux piece it's not real peace
yeah and i think for our income level i
think that we're okay
i think the biggest increase is about
130
um thousand per year yeah great how old
are you guys
um so i just barely turned 28 and then
my wife is 24. well you've done a good
job saving you've done a sucky job
with debt yep and you haven't done a
good job organizing all of this and you
just kind of go buy stuff whenever you
want to
that's right and you can clean all this
up in one fell swoop
because you've been savings good yep and
here's what will happen when you get out
of debt you don't have any money
i mean you got a 20 000 bucks or so in
your emergency fund you don't have any
debt except your
new home and be sure to put that on a
15-year fixed by the way
not a 30. uh then what you're probably
going to do because you're a natural
saver you're probably going to put some
more in that emergency fund
before you start investing because that
21 000 is not enough for you
to feel comfortable that's not really
that's
maybe three months of expenses but it's
not six months and you probably want six
months since you're a saver
by nature yep but you're gonna have to
stop the stupid with the debt
which means as you write these checks
you guys are looking at each other
saying we're not doing anything else
like prime example dave i feel this in
my bones i do it's not the cold weather
either it's wisdom
because you buy a new house and guess
what you gotta buy new furniture
yeah oh you gotta get furniture because
you got the new house you need a new
couch the old couch can't come to the
new house
yes it can too cause it's a couch
okay slow down they do what they're told
slow
down you're trying to do everything at
this light speed and i'm telling you it
increases debt back
into your life move with the furniture
that you have
sit down make a plan that you're going
to save up and you're going to pay cash
for furnishing the home yeah yeah and if
there's some rooms that are unfurnished
guess what
it's fine throw a box in there go sit
down on it it'll be fine
but i'm telling you this from wisdom
because i've done that stupid
where you feel this com being compelled
to do things
before you have the money and which ends
you it back in debt
so colton take a deep breath buddy write
checks clean this
up and move forward with your financial
future on a whole nother level
you guys need to get plugged into ramsey
plus the problem is you
you've not had a plan you guys have just
kind of been doing yeah that's that's
good
that's good you know i was just sitting
here thinking in the 60s
it was 1960s it was very difficult to
borrow to buy furniture
it was unusual and so my mom and dad
moved into
a 1 000 square foot uh three bedroom
one and a half bath ranch house with a
full basement in it
and um i remember most
of my life my younger light years anyway
up until maybe
i don't know 12 years old
our living room didn't have any
furniture in it
had this wonderful green shag carpet
that you had to rake
remember the rake you're right shade
carpet no dude you have to rake it it
had like a grain to it
and when you got finished vacuuming it
you had to rake it it like was like
cutting grass and so
but there was no furniture in there
until uh because we had the money to buy
furniture and you couldn't buy it they
wouldn't
i mean at least regular people i mean
rich people i guess could but i guess
regular people couldn't borrow money
because there was no rooms there they
went i mean it was just wow
there was you know no nothing down on a
couch or zero percent interest until
your taxes when does good stuff come
aboard that in the 80s
70s and big time in the 80s big time in
the 80s it started showing up in the
mid to late 70s is the first time uh 90
days same as cash particularly
uh big in the 80s and uh moved on from
there but i mean it's just
so my point is that you're correct that
it's okay to save up and pay cash for
furniture
it sure is even if it's a few years
which in his case is not going to be he
makes plenty of money buying that gum
couch but i had a friend of mine he went
to goodwill
got some furniture for a room and he
said when we get the money
one piece will leave at a time and i
never thought this guy would be that
kind of person but he put his pride
aside
and he goes we're not going to let this
rush us he could we've done stupid
before
and we bought a 6 000 leather couch
for 600 bucks at a garage sale on the
rich people into town
yep that's what we did it was a great
leather couch i wish i had that leather
couch it was awesome
and it's probably still okay because
that leather lasts forever oh yeah it
was real cow
but yeah it was like a real cow and um
comfortable too but it was real
expensive
yeah rich people stuff and we bought it
for 600 bucks because they just changed
the color out you know mama's
redecorating oh yeah whatever over there
on that end
yeah man it's amazing what happens if we
can change our thinking they probably
wish
they had that counterpart
this is the ramsay show